und wir beginnen mit unbegreiflichen
szenen nach einem schrecklichen lkw
unfall auf der a2 in brandenburg
es sind bilder die fassungslos machen
mit kippe und bierflasche stehen diese
männer neben der autobahn und garten
während sich wenige meter entfernt
grausame szenen abspielen auf der a2 kam
es zu einem schweren unfall ein brummi
fahrer sitzt in seinem lkw eingeklemmt
die rettungskräfte können den man nicht
befreien er verbrennt bei lebendigem
leib diese männer schauen zu dürfen
trinken bier und haben nichts besseres
zu tun als dabei zuzusehen wie ein mann
in seinem fahrerhaus verbrennt auf der
a2 in brandenburg in höhe berlin war es
zu einem furchtbaren unfall gekommen ein
lkw fahrer hatte wohl aus unachtsamkeit
das stauende übersehen und krachte auf
einen stehenden uni der geht sofort in
flammen auf die flammen schlagen um sich
explosionen für den fahrer kommt jede
hilfe zu spät der fahrer verbrennt im
führerhaus
widerlich während sich dieses drama
abspielt stehen diese männer wenige
meter entfernt machen sich auch noch
lustig beleidigen die einsatzkräfte und
zeigen um den stinkefinger die
rettungskräfte können das verhalten
dieser männer nicht fassen da drüben die
zwei bürger die stehen ja am
wildschutzzaun an der b2 müssen
vermutlich durch den wald hier reinigung
sein und stehen da drüben märz mit einer
flasche bier in der hand teilweise
brauchen die dort im wald bei warnstufe
5 zigarette wie gesagt und beleidigen
hier die einsatzkräfte mit mittelfinger
also es geht gar nicht so persönlich
macht es mich natürlich auch innerlich
aggressiv wir sind ja alle ehrenamtlich
wir haben familien zu hause wir haben
andere sachen zu tun auch privat wm und
dann ist traurig dass vom bürger nicht
mal irgendwie der nötige respekt da ist
dass leute ihre freizeit opfern um
anderen menschen das leben zu retten
deutliche worte aber nicht nur die
rettungskräfte auch die autofahrer
verurteilung das kreiste und pietätlose
verhalten der unglaublich preisniveau an
der a 2 das kann ich überhaupt nicht
verstehen ich habe mich wirklich wo ich
im auto verhalten habe hier abgewartet
und möchte keinen weg sein weil da geht
es teilweise um leben und das kann ich
nicht behindern und das recht nicht die
leute in ihrer arbeiter beleidigen weil
die machen das ehrenamtlich und
freiwillig der unfall ist gerade vor mir
passiert und ich bin immer sehr dankbar
wenn die kollegen von der freiwilligen
feuerwehr hier sind gab richtig heftige
explosionen nach zehn minuten kamen die
ersten rettungskräfte stehen der ersten
reihe und bin sehr dankbar dass die
jungs da jedes mal
ein brummifahrer top trend in seinem lkw
und diese männer schauen zu trinken bier
brauchen und verhöhnen die
rettungskräfte
gaffen obwohl es eigentlich geächtet ist
passiert das immer wieder und ein mann
ist er wohl dreisteste gaffer
deutschland ergibt sich nämlich als
gutachter aus
dreister geht es kaum hier gibt sich ein
cover als gutachter aus
der nordring in nürnberg als ein hyundai
fahrer verbotswidrig wendet kann ein
nachfolgender motorradfahrer nicht mehr
rechtzeitig ausweichen
die 32-jährige rast mit seiner maschine
in das auto wird durch die luft
geschleudert und landet auf der anderen
straßenseite der biker kommt mit
lebensgefährlichen verletzungen ins
krankenhaus ebenso wie der leicht
verletzte fahrer
und dann das während die polizei die
unfallstelle sichert und zeugen befragt
taucht auf einmal ein mann auf und macht
fotos auf nachfrage gibt er sich als
gutachter aus eine dreiste lüge die
beamten warten zwar auf einem
sachverständigen doch die kennen sie in
der regel und diesen mann kennt ihn
niemand
sofort greift eine polizistin ein
kontrolliert die personalien des mannes
und fordert ihn auf die ihm gemachten
fotos zu löschen
sie warten ab ich bin
die sich unverstanden machen bilder und
immer nicht
ein weiterer beamter kommt dazu und
stellt sicher dass die coverbilder auch
wirklich und endgültig gelöscht werden
erst dann kann der mann den unfallort
verlassen
von einsicht allerdings keine spur der
crash hätte ihn einfach interessiert
die genaue unfallursache ist noch nicht
bekannt die verkehrspolizei nürnberg hat
die ermittlungen übernommen
auch ob der gaffer mit rechtlichen
konsequenzen rechnen muss ist unklar
[Musik]